[Musica]
[Applauso]
oggi penso che abbiamo un grosso
problema con i congiuntivi
non so voi ma io quando vado sui social
network del campo di post c'è veramente
da mettersi le mani nei capelli
oltre congiuntivi credo che abbiamo un
problema anche con le coniugazioni il
futuro non so voi ma io la frase se
potessi mi andrei subito all'estero l'ho
sentito veramente troppo troppo spesso
voi sapete quanti sono gli italiani che
ogni anno decidono di andare via dal
nostro paese
vediamo facciamo un gioco alzi la mano
chi penserà ci siano più di 50.000 ok
più di 100 mila tir i 150 mila gli
italiani
oplà italiani che ogni anno vanno via
dall'italia sono circa 285.000 la
maggior parte sono diplomati laureati
che vanno via dal nostro paese alla
nostra terra alla ricerca di migliori
condizioni lavorative di vita nel cui
percorso di studio lo stato ha investito
9 miliardi di euro
una perdita da un punto di vista di
capitale umano secondo studi
confindustria di oltre 1 per cento del
pil all anno
ma se da un lato abbiamo il problema
della fuga dei cervelli dall'altro siamo
anche il peggior paese in europa per
quanto riguarda il fenomeno de netta un
italiano su quattro tra i 15 e 29 anni
non studia non lavora e non si sta
formando un potenziale inespresso che ci
voglia un altro 2 per cento del pil
all'anno
e così ci ritroviamo in un paese che ha
il 30 per cento di disoccupazione
giovanile e sapete qual è il paradosso
in tutto questo è che si stima che ogni
anno in italia ci siano oltre 100 mila
offerte di lavoro alle quali gli
imprenditori
fatevi un altro la risposta molte delle
quali sarebbero accessibili con un
diploma tecnico professionale con una
laurea in ambito tecnico scientifico
questo succede perché esiste un mismatch
tra le competenze acquisite dai ragazzi
nel percorso di formazione e quelle
richieste dal mondo del lavoro
secondo l'ocse abbiamo pochi laureati e
per giunta
nei settori meno richiesti quindi ci
ritroviamo a tantissimi laureati
chiamano a svolgere lavori sotto
menzionati rispetto alla propria
formazione
secondo il world economic forum il 65
per cento dei bambini che oggi la scuola
ora che si finirà il proposito ciclo
scolastico fra dei lavori che
attualmente ancora non esistono e tutte
le fonti tutti dati sono concordi che
siamo di fronte a una rivoluzione
pazzesca un fenomeno ben più forte e più
importante di quello che c'è stata in
italia nel secondo dopoguerra quando ai
lavoratori del settore agricoltura sono
passati dal 60 al 10 per cento della
popolazione e vedete qua per affrontare
queste grandi sfide che ci attendono
secondo me bisogna i punti chiavi sono
due il primo andare a intercettare
meglio le richieste nel mondo a lavoro
con quello della formazione e l'altro
creare delle politiche di orientamento
per i ragazzi perché se noi oggi voci
simoni qui e incontrassimo dieci ragazzi
otto ragazzi su 10 non sarà
assolutamente da fare dopo il diploma
dopo la laurea nella nella propria vita
e secondo me per risolvere quest'ultimo
problema bisogna partire raccontando
parlando e ragazzi di tre concetti tre
pilastri fondamentali che sono il
talento il successo e il coraggio
sono queste i tre punti sul quale
edificare il nostro miglior futuro
e io credo che per una società la vera
sfida
anzi la vera disfida visto ci siano
barletta è quella di riuscire a
costruire una società e un'economia
basata sul talento se ne cercassimo la
parola talento sul dizionario uscirebbe
fuori predisposizione che qualcuno ha
nei confronti di qualcosa prima persona
che sa far meglio una cosa rispetto a
un'altra cosa quindi non rispetto a
un'altra persona e ognuno di noi ha un
talento ha una predisposizione diversa
chi ha il disegno che l'informatica chi
al contatto umano e io penso che il
talento si identifica anche con la
nostra anima e quindi il compito nella
nostra vita è quello di esprimerlo di
tirarlo fuori perché se noi non
assecondiamo il nostro talento il nostro
io sicuramente
non viviamo in pace con noi stessi non
siamo sicuramente felici di quello che
stiamo facendo
poi ovvio attenzione bisogna neanche
confondere il la passione con il talento
perché io possa avere la passione del
gioco del calcio ma non avere il talento
per fare il calciatore e mitico fantozzi
un ragioniere e può essere quindi che
bisogna intercettare quest'asse che
trattamento e la passione senza
dimenticarci l'impegno perché tu puoi
avere un talento pazzesco ma siano lo
coltivi non non ti alleni giorno dopo
giorno non andrai mai da nessuna parte
perché è l'impegno senza il talento
batte sempre il talento senza impegno
il secondo concetto è successo questo è
un tema veramente particolarmente a
cuore perché credo che la mia
generazione le generazioni dopo la mia
non ho ben chiaro cosa voglia dire
veramente raggiungere il successo è
speso si identifica il successo con il
guadagnare molti soldi con la popolarità
con il numero di followers sui vari
social network e o il numero di like
invece è successo come dicevo prima è
riuscire a realizzare quello che si è
per realizzare il proprio talento
riuscire veramente a ad ascoltare entro
le stessi e realizzare questa cosa e
quando nelle scuole devo raccontare cosa
vuol dire secondo me raggiungere il
successo
mi viene in mente sempre questa storia
di barack obama quando era giovane
barack obama da giovane quando è stato
eletto primo presidente afroamericano
degli stati uniti molti in molti
giornalisti sono andati intervistare i
suoi amici d'infanzia nel paese nativo
alle hawaii per sedere appunto come er
ne fosse obama la giovane e tra questi
hanno intervistato l'orologiaio della
città nativa di obama nell'intervista
che mi ha colpito più di tutte perché
racconta ha raccontato un aneddoto di
quando allora i due erano giovani e sono
andati erano in riva al mare di sera a
vedere le stelle certo punto c'è una
stella cadente e quindi l'amico dice
obama barack c'è una stella cadente
esprime il desiderio e il se io sogno un
giorno di poter diventare il primo
presidente afroamericano degli stati
uniti
invece l'amico disse io sogno un giorno
di diventare l'orologiaio di questa
città intera costa queste cose e a
questa troupe televisiva che lo stava
intervistando si gira verso la
telecamera e disse hai visto barak
alla fine ce l'abbiamo fatta tutti e due
quindi questa veramente dire veramente
raggiungere il successo al di là dei
soldi che si guadagnano della popolarità
e soprattutto un'altra cosa che abbiamo
bisogno soprattutto noi come generazione
e capire che c'è bisogno di tempo non si
raggiunge un successo e immediatamente
bisogna saper aspettare
purtroppo siamo la generazione che vive
di gratificazione istantanea
vogliamo un paio di scarpe andiamo su
internet contiamo c'era una subita a
casa
dobbiamo guardare un film e non dobbiamo
aspettare i tempi della televisione ad
aspettare venerdì alle ore 21 no se lo
vogliono guardano anche adesso a
mezzanotte alle 5 del mattino quando
voglio quindi non siamo più veramente
capaci di aspettare e abbiamo tutto a
portata di click di app anche le
relazioni attraverso facebook instagram
kinder
quindi ragazzi ormai non si relazionano
più soltanto attraverso le relazioni
perché più veloce come cosa è promesso
le relazioni secondo me c'è un sì un un
esempio prevale noi siamo non siamo più
capaci di aspettare chiediamo subito in
ansia nel panico ed è questo la doppia
spunta blu di vozza a perché andiamo in
ansia il panico se uno si visualizza non
si risponde su aerei salvare non so
quante relazioni sono finite o dio
visualizzato non mi ha risposto
sicuramente a un'altra quindi resta
sicuramente un'altra cosa che bisogna
bisogna capire perchè dico tutto questo
perché veramente bisogna far capire
ragazzi che le cose che veramente
contano nella vita i successi del lavoro
dello studio hanno bisogno di tempo non
esiste un'app non esistono click che
bisogna a bisogna aspettare e bisogna
c'è bisogno del nostro tempo e del
nostro tempo perché ognuno ha un tempo
non ogni tanto l'errore che si fa e
pensare o cavoli quali nemica 30 anni è
già a casa già famiglia più avanti di me
nel percorso di vita oppure pensare che
dopo alcune più indietro no ognuno ha i
propri tempi quindi hanno bisogno
mentre mai nessuno e soprattutto nei
stessi di accelerare i nostri tempi
l'ultima l'ultimo pilastro il coraggio
se ci pensiamo la paura è una di quelle
sensazioni che ci accompagna
costantemente nella nostra vita magari
con l'obiettivo di riuscire opporre
resistenza al cambiamento è una paura di
perdere di perdersi o magari anche di
sognare sono i troppo grandi e riguarda
tantissimi aspetti nella vita
pensiamo per esempio l'amore quante
persone rimangano una storia d'amore già
finita
parla pure di quello che può succedere
dopo o quante persone rimangano un
lavoro li sta bruciando giorno dopo
giorno tra la paura di non trovarne uno
più adatto alle proprie esigenze o
quanti ragazzi si iscrivano al percorso
di studi sbagliato per il timore di non
dover cambiare la propria vita
se ci pensiamo alle scelte fatte sulla
spinta la paura sono sorretti anche dei
ragionamenti che possono sembrare
ineccepibili e suggellati magari dal
marchio di garanzia del pensiero
dominante perché tutti pensano così la
mia famiglia mi dice così i miei amici
mi dicono così
quante volte mi ha sentito frasi come si
ho capito che lavoro che stai facendo
non ti piace ti trovi male ma sei matto
a lasciarlo con la crisi lavoro che c'è
in giro e per cosa poi
per inseguire questa utopia della
realizzazione personale ma scendi dalle
nuvole cresce signora vivo che tu vuoi
fare medicina vorresti fare il medico
ma tanto si sa in italia va avanti
soltanto i raccomandati e soltanto i
fili di medici lascia stare medicina
studi economia tuo padre commercialista
sei studi economia avere la certezza di
un lavoro
prova a pensare questo e cresci e così
paura dopo paura si cresce in realtà si
diventa sempre più piccoli quasi
rattrappiti e la sofferenza da quelle
scelte di paura provano a proteggerci in
realtà si presenta sotto altra forma
come la depressione l'ansia la mancanza
di poter ambire a qualcosa di meglio
adesso qui non voglio sembrare quello
che non sa più degli altri assolutamente
credo di avere tutta da imparare da
tutti ma una cosa l'ho capita e che non
esistono scelte giuste o sbagliate in
assoluto
resistono scelte di coraggio e scelte di
paura scelte di passione e scelte
ricalcolo e le prime sono sempre i
migliori anche se all'inizio possono
sembrare più difficili
percorre poi certo bisogna saper
distinguere il coraggio dell'incoscienza
e non posso pensare di fare l'astronauta
stando seduto sul divano anche se è
bello cielo di un giorno mi metto
anch'io si deve essere fantastica
veramente e poi anche vero che magari
alcuni ragazzi non sanno ancora cosa
fare nella propria vita non hanno ancora
idee e io penso a questo momento della
vita come la spedizione di cristoforo
colombo che cavolo sempre cristoforo
colombo con mio figlio che magari a
vent'anni uno stato da fare la dieta ci
siamo cristoforo colombo ha scoperto
l'america ma lui voleva partire per lui
è partito per le indie quindi è partito
per l'india in realtà scoperto l'america
questa cosa mi ha fatto pensare che in
realtà nessuno di noi
nessun viaggiatore sa veramente così il
viaggio e quindi la vita ci porterà a
fare però mettersi in viaggio ci
costringe a fare due cose la prima è
mettersi alla ricerca e la seconda
all'ascolto di noi stessi e io sono
sicuro che chi parte e fisicamente o
mentalmente per cercare ciò chiama
finirà quasi sicuramente per amare ciò
che trova grazie
[Applauso]